for most of History conservatives have
been the party of Restraint of limits of
humility and Prudence Prudence
considered by Aristotle the Paramount
political virtue this reputation
suffered a wee little bit of damage in
the mid 2000s thanks to the rise of the
neoconservatives of the Bush era who
advocated an ambitious downright
wilsonian foreign policy that never saw
a foreign Backwater that it did not want
to bomb and Conquer but the aberration
of the wilsonian right has receded once
again in recent years Donald Trump for
instance campaigned on restraint on
avoiding war and focusing on the home
front how's that possible Donald Trump
doesn't know anything about foreign
policy I think actually that's part of
the explanation Trump's lack of foreign
policy wonk bonafides seems to have
served him pretty well perhaps because
he never thought that he had all the
answers and he consistently preferred
modest victories to grandiose conquests